[Music]
so you guys ever played with dry ice yes
yes I made a lot of drinks with dry ice
Oh to never touch it and shouldn't touch
forever you can't touch it you use tongs
and let melt
it's social sciences it looks like it's
the best Halloween drink concoction
maker you can definitely get the wait
for it to melt all the way so you just
like a little tiny piece or you put it
in a big cauldron and then you're not
scooping the bottom of it you're just
sweeping the top of it I put a piece in
my mouth like a jawbreaker once when I
was like 12 and definitely regretted it
did you die did it stick
no kidding I'll completely laugh I do
that sometimes I think you would die
without teeth bro yeah it would burn
your [ __ ] tongue off yeah probably
oh my god okay well is it melts yeah
yeah can you kill somebody with that I'm
sure if you if they ate it yeah like it
would burn their insight oh so a Russian
Instagram star with over 1 million
followers recently celebrated her 29th
birthday by having this big old pool
party with dry eyes in the pool no
according to some sources people said
that her husband was the one that had a
really great idea of putting dry ice
into the pool to dazzle the guests with
a smoky reaction and then I keep jumped
in and then like three people holy [ __ ]
yeah details Tiffani I will show you the
video
oh no [ __ ] ton of dry ice in there oh
you feel like 55 kilos oh yeah 25
kilograms which is like 55 holy [ __ ] man
well here we go read watch a live death
no sir whole video is there a whole
video is it on life that guy in
particular dire we don't know
so for not to know her husband died
Jesus so I'm assuming he's the one that
jumped in I don't know for sure but this
is the this is a girl and then this was
her husband and they have two kids
together so what exactly killed him the
skin lacerations were like it got inside
him the patient suffocation wait I
didn't cause it was going to much too
much smoke or later yeah well they're
saying that because of the reaction with
the water it's like immediately once the
dry ice was dumped guests started
coughing and chlorine probably too they
lost art losing consciousness there were
severe cases of chemical burns but the
thing is that by putting the dry ice in
there and the fact that it's enclosed to
in the fact that it was so much dry ice
like if just it was a bad combination
yeah that was a lot of that's a lot of
dry ice frozen carbon dioxide
yeah so they're breathing in carbon
dioxide oh so it's melting and there's
just filling up with carbon drafts got
it it's dangerous gas so chlorine that's
like so why we have carbon dioxide
detectors in our house and he just
[ __ ] inject my dioxide
Oh carbon monoxide yeah but you're cute
it's supposed to [ __ ] me you're not
supposed to breathe that [ __ ] for every
negative it's a good hey you know why
nobody knows what the [ __ ] the
differences between dioxide and my oxide
so one is one one asleep yes thank you
mono yeah nobody even gives a [ __ ]
either
except one like when it's a detect it's
going off yeah well yeah I care about my
Mars went often firefighters came over
we did you know what's crazy about this
story to me that is really interesting
that no one really points this out but
the girl the influencer chick her name
is Katrina she is a qualified pharmacist
and she is known like her water
following is posting tips about how to
use like home remedies for illnesses so
she wanted him dead wait is she man ty
Baxter
I don't know mmm essential oils no but
no she needs her toys money saving tips
in C when buying pharmaceutical products
so most people wouldn't even buy
pharmaceutical products mmm she's they
qualified pharmacist and she didn't know
this would happen
she's like huh that's weird maybe she I
don't know she could have skated her way
through school and then was like I'm
gonna build a brand around this and
doesn't really know I was a system in
Russia
I don't know so she posted this photo
morning of like her birth you know
that's creepy they literally recorded a
video yes that's what's weird about
watching that [ __ ] yeah
that's like my other guess so it's three
fatalities so they suffocated - yeah
they jumped in after seeing him from
like that you're gonna try to save him
Oh probably he thought he was having a
good time and he was drunk or so he
thought they were all wearing a suzhou
that's whistles crazily I knew something
was that that's what I was thinking -
they didn't all show up in bikinis
strange and then I'm now the mom like
the influencer she's she has been
posting photos or like videos on her
social media accounts like crying saying
that hurt her daughter's asking like
where's daddy and that she doesn't know
what it tells hit her as she did she
promised I'll have a better birthday
party next year I don't even know how to
eat now the [ __ ] with it
like how do you have a birthday how do
you birthday party you wanted to make a
party after this [ __ ] man Jesus being a
cool way to die but I don't want to make
them wait was that part of the joke well
it's not
it looks cool to jump into that look
cool down no it's okay you're very
pretty
looks cool bro
yeah that's saying this is Russia Russia
be wildin I'm not Russian can handle the
cold I'm kidding there's too many
I know Gina if we were lesser people we
would make those jokes no weekend maybe
I should have saved the fact that you
does yes room sorry
it's sad though I just I feel like
that's how cuz I can't really process
death that well other than to like yeah
just life of comedy mm-hmm
so what else is your brain thinking oh
because I don't think of one person
dying I think of how we're all all of
our mortalities and how everyone I love
is gonna die eventually and then and
then I just yeah I'm just thinking about
Vanessa
I was just thinking about it I can't
stop thinking about it every day I'm
like do I have to unfollow her do I just
keep it going because I can't be living
like that that's not me she's in the
same scenario like like husband's there
next day gone like that that's terrible
the difference here is that she could
have prevented it yeah he could have
yeah they didn't know she's a pharmacist
that's a tip just said no you're cute
though that far for like medicine I
think they don't know like that would be
like a scientist okay let's go to every
pharmacy in America take a piece of dry
ice and water and just look threatening
in front of all of them you see if they
tell us about big I don't think they're
gonna care go up to a pharmacist with a
with a little igloo container and open
up and be like hey I have a question
about this I pictured an actual area
like a baby
igloo and there you go this is cute tell
em no but she's cute you have to give a
positive cute sounds condescending take
it what's it what's a good adjective for
men to be called handsome I'm sexy
pretty gorgeous beautiful you be use cue
but you have to say to me oh look at you
so Q you had like oh like what if I call
him and what if I'm like he's bad that's
like calling me a rebel like what's that
red bomb like first of all what's a red
phone you don't want a red bonus you're
cute yeah oh my god thank god you're
kidding are you
rebel is what they call they refer to
light like skin like sex they blow look
a red barn over there
was supposed to because she's got a
little bit of Native it or sometimes
read it something like that our skin has
like a red tone to it what do you think
red mom yeah that's like you have a
little bit of communism in you always
confidently wrong yeah you should see me
trying to find my own car sometimes I
know it's [ __ ] way I parked it if I'm
driving and I could go two different
directions always the wrong I always go
the wrong way every single time like you
gotta go that way he's like no no I mean
I'll watch this [ __ ] and then I'm wrong
wow that was crazy we call redbone is
bed yeah okay and like if I called me
pig what damn good for ladies oh he's
got a big dick no that's great okay oh
wait he's goofy big dick that's fine
it's fine and girthy three c's thick thi
see see see oh that's how you know you
really how do you not know that no I
thought like seem effort yeah like yeah
like too confident like there's thick
when there's you know I would think
there's more eyes than that but we
always fell it with the sense this is
like a I put more ease on dinner wise
I'm like wow
my point also when I say like yes I'm
going yes Oh before I just do why oh
yeah oh yeah when I'm like when I'm like
in love love like love love I call them
beautiful
Oh beautiful thing I've ever seen like
that's that's what I'm like in you guys
like that me like gorgeous as well when
she called you beautiful that means you
go on wrong oh dude cause you beautiful
just know you're going wrong at night
yeah I feel like I was with him oh and I
busted without permission and men should
do as mentioned I know yeah we just
found that out Steve yeah it was we're
very connected that's all yeah did you
were you worried no no I was like that's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] thing to do Oh in that
kind of way but I like him does anyone
else we known each other a long time so
so you just came in her yeah it was fun
I was like he's been in a four-year
relationship he doesn't know that you're
supposed to ask I guess the benefit of
the doubt but the second time I wasn't
exactly thinking about the rules
obviously you already knew at that point
so that's it well but for those that
need to know Kaiser has Plan B for $20
and you don't have to be a member or
members are free
no it's deal to the house just join
[Music]